I'm sure you heard about this
benphotamine vitamin so what's all the
hype in do we really need it and what is
it good for benphotamine is a fat
soluble B1 normally B1 called thymine is
water-soluble and so there's several
advantages of having this vitamin in a
fat soluble form number one it can
penetrate membranes that are made out of
fat much easier like by a factor of 360
percent more penetration so benfotamine
is really good for anything neurological
anything brain especially peripheral
neuropathy where you have the bottom of
your feet tingling numbness burning or
that could be on the hands as well so
what is it actually doing one of the big
things it's doing it's inhibiting the
formation of something called
ages that stands for advanced glycation
and products now what is that well
that's basically this uh formation of
sugar with a protein or sugar with fat
that's
um morphed into this unusable protein so
for example when you are a diabetic and
you test for blood glucose levels a lot
of times they'll do what's called A1C
and that test measures for this term
glycation which basically means how much
damage to your proteins in your blood is
occurring like the hemoglobin is protein
right so they can measure how much of
that protein is unusable because it's
glycated because all the sugar interacts
with the protein and kind of fuses it to
make it unavailable and so as the red
blood cell is unavailable guess what you
get you get a lot of complications from
that one being just lowered amount of
the ability to carry oxygen and think
about the Cascade of effects that that
can create also this glycation starts to
accumulate in the mitochondria and it
plugs up the machinery for your cells so
benphotamine is a very potent
antioxidant type nutrient that inhibits
the formation of this glycation it also
supports the myelin sheath that outer
covering of the nerve that allows the
nerve to actually work and in a deeper
level we need B1 desperately for several
enzymes in our mitochondria involved in
metabolism certain enzymes are dependent
on B1 and if your cells don't have B1
boy all sorts of issues start occurring
so a lot of the complications
especially from diabetes occur because
of this lack of this B1 because the more
glucose you have flowing through your
bloodstream the more B1 you need so by
being a diabetic you're basically
sucking up all that residual B1 that you
had leaving you high and dry now there
are four main tissues in the body that
are affected by diabetes more than any
other tissues in the body
okay we have the nerve and the Brain
kind of the same tissue we have the
arteries
we have the I and we have the kidney
now what's so unique about these four
tissues well number one they're the most
metabolically demanding tissues of your
body which means they hog a lot of fuel
and they also require a lot of oxygen
and then they as a byproduct they put
out a lot of oxidation so that means
these four tissues are very susceptible
to problems with too much oxidation and
basically that means that your balance
of antioxidants versus your oxidants are
out of balance you don't have enough
antioxidants to handle the amount of
oxidation occurring and you can kind of
think about oxidation as kind of
something rusting out in the body and so
the term for that is called oxidative
stress so these four tissues are very
susceptible
to becoming damaged with high levels of
sugar because of the oxidation and the
inability to repair and so B1 can come
in there to the rescue and lower this
oxidation because it's kind of a very
potent antioxidant another thing that
happens in diabetes is you have damage
to the micro circulation the tiny
capillaries that feed these tissues
these capillary walls start to leak and
you get bleeding and you especially see
this in arteries you see this in the
eyes it happens in the kidney and so on
a deeper level we're getting all this
glycated protein junk that's
accumulating in the mitochondria
plugging everything up and literally
starving the cells of fuel and oxygen
that's why you see peripheral neuropathy
showing up as a kind of a
one of the first things because it
affects the extremities at the farthest
distance from the heart this Advanced
glycation end product compound that's
plugging everything up can come from
several things it comes from eating
sugar with protein when it's cooked it
comes from eating sugar and fat when
it's cooked that would be like ice cream
would be a perfect example it comes from
cooking in high Heats like you're deep
frying something or you're grilling
something where something is very crispy
you do get a certain amount of glycation
but just being a diabetic causes high
levels of glycation as you get older you
have more glycation so age is a big
factor if you smoke if you drink alcohol
and the more inflammation you have the
more glycation you're going to have this
is why benphotamine for diabetics is so
vitally important because it basically
just starts slowing down this glycation
process and getting rid of the
complications from diabetes and of
course hopefully that person is getting
rid of the real cause of diabetes
diabetes which is the diet but sometimes
the doctors don't really emphasize that
they're all about managing your blood
sugars well eventually you need to fix
the cause but also benphotamine can help
you with the symptoms along the way
and also many times people combine alpha
lipoic acid with benphotamine because
they're a bit synergistic the alpha
lipoic acid directly targets
inflammation as well as that oxidative
stress whereas benphotamine does that as
well but it also supplies you with the
necessary B1 for the enzymes in the
mitochondria as well as directly
inhibiting the formation of that
glycation now inside your arteries okay
you have this little inside layer of the
artery and it's called the Tunica intima
which means innermost layer and in that
layer there's a superficial layer of
cells and they're just like one cell
thick
that are exposed to blood going through
the arteries and that's called the
endothelial layer that layer of cells
boy that controls blood pressure it
controls all sorts of hormonal
interactions it gets hammered with this
oxidative stress and then you start
getting inflammation and you start
getting scar tissue and then you start
getting more clots one of the things
that it does is it helps to prevent
clots but if it becomes damaged you
start getting clots and there's also
micro blood vessels that are supplying
the artery walls those are called Vasa
vasorum which means the vessels of the
vessels so the blood vessels also need
blood to survive and so all this high
level of concentrated sugar in that area
starts to create inflammation in those
vessels which are a little bit deeper
and then you start getting thickening of
the arteries and stiffness of the
arteries which is not just going to lead
to blood pressure problems but a
constriction of blood that's flowing
through the arteries in other words
insulin is
anti-atherosclerosis in other words it
prevents this whole Cascade problem wait
a second I thought that too much insulin
is bad
well it is but you have this other
factor involved it's called insulin
resistance so a lot of these
complications that are occurring from
high glucose and high insulin are
occurring because you actually have a
deficiency of insulin because of the
resistance because the body makes more
but it never actually gets to the right
target to allow things to occur and so
by doing things to get rid of insulin
resistance you actually get more insulin
to heal this whole area so by eating
things that increase insulin it never is
a good solution we have the arteries
that are involve we also have the
kidneys that get destroyed and so when
you have this kidney filter that gets
destroyed you start getting this
leakiness in the filter so the holes
become bigger and then protein kind of
goes out and then sugar kind of goes out
and then you can no longer recycle this
and so the kidneys start losing their
filtration now in the eyes you have this
effect especially from the retina which
is nerve tissue that's extending from
the brain and it's actually out in the
open and so it's very susceptible to
this oxidation and so this is why a
diabetic could eventually lose their
eyesight to go blind but guess what
benphotamine can come in there and slow
this process down from happening and
hopefully even reverse it in certain
circumstances now when we get nerve
damage from this process it's not just
the nerves in our feet it's not just the
neurons in our brain which is also
considered type 3 diabetes but you also
get destruction of the autonomic nervous
system there's something called diabetic
autonomic neuropathy it can exist in any
part of your autonomic nervous system so
in summary then photamine can greatly
help a diabetic in many different ways
it can actually help reduce this filling
up with the mitochondria with this
glycation end products it can increase
the number of mitochondria which can
increase the ATP the fuel to these
tissues but remember you also want to
get on the correct eating plan at the
same time and if you have any questions
on that you need to watch this video
right here